[Music]
where do I start with can of worms just
imagine you're channel surfing and
suddenly you come across this those are
just the table scraps of insanity that
this special has to offer it's the
craziest goddamn thing I've ever seen I
mean it's absolutely ludicrous and dumb
and not good and I don't even have the
words for it the story if you can call
it that centers around a kid named
Michael just listen to a couple seconds
of him
thousands of spaceships bristling with
with force fields and weapons surrounded
the planet video motion that would be
doomed doomed yep that's the kind of
performers you gotta put up with this
whole film you see Michael is a bit of a
nerd so much so that he believes he's
from another planet
yeah not make believes believes believes
he constantly tells stories to this
little kid and he acts like it's real he
tells himself that he can't be but he
can't help but shake the feeling that
maybe he is I'll put that on the back
burner for about 40 minutes
yeah there's no talk of aliens or
anything like that for 40 minutes in
this hour and 20 minute movie instead we
focus on how he sucks at football yep
the lead cheerleader of course falls in
love with him and asks him to help her
put together all the decorations for the
Halloween dance he uses all his computer
skills and nerdy technology to make it a
big hit but the bully sabotage it
causing him to run out in a panic what
does he do he goes to his giant space
satellite you know like every kid has
and sends out a message to the universe
that he is being held there hostage and
wants to be taken to another galaxy
again like most kids would a fulfilled
life nullified by the errand and cool
indigenous popular
lightning strikes the satellite and he
soon forgets about it until a dog
voiced by Malcolm McDowell arrives
telling him that he's from a nonprofit
organization that wants to take him to a
world where he'll feel more comfortable
but wait it gets stranger soon other
aliens start to arrive for various
reasons one wants to make a lawsuit out
of him and sue the earth another wants
to sell the rights to his story to make
an intergalactic movie another wants to
be his agent
it just gets stranger and stranger but
then things get really out of hand when
one comes to kidnap him for a zoo
accidentally stealing his little friend
and they have to go in and save him
while also saving one of the aliens he
thought he was in the story he was
talking about in the beginning yeah it
looks like they're real how did he know
about him how does he know how to open
their cage and use some of their devices
it is never explained they never say
whether or not Michael is an alien or a
boy they never explain how we got all
this information it just ends with him
heading Malcolm MacDonald dog behind the
ears so long yeah this is exactly as
goddamn insane as it sounds I guess from
the oddness of the story and kind of a
satirical edge you can maybe get a few
jokes out of it maybe there's some
possibilities for it it's just so damn
strange but no none of it goes together
the story is horrendous the writing is
ridiculous all the acting is
over-the-top none of it makes any
goddamn sense
the only thing kind of interesting about
it is the design of the aliens I mean I
have to give credit these are some
pretty bizarre out there puppets but
aside from that I have no idea what I
just watched this has got to be the
friggin weirdest thing Disney Channel
has ever put on TV and that's saying
quite a bit even my kid movie standards
it's ridiculous the first 40 minutes
almost nothing happens except you watch
him get ready for this dance and then
the rest of it is all this talk about
lawsuits and signing contracts and stuff
that a lot of kids probably wouldn't
follow it and it's it's just stupid it's
so stupid
you just can't believe what you're
watching half the time the only way I
can think to describe it is the Santa
Claus versus the Martians of
is neat channel movies it's not just bad
its laughably bad and I think even kids
that watch it wouldn't know how dumb it
is I guess on that level it's kind of
entertaining I mean how could anyone
predict where any of this was going to
go but if you want something that's
entertaining on say a kids level and
adults level a satirical level a
charming level or performances that
don't look like Walter Benes yet doing
Zack Snyder then this probably isn't the
movie for you
and if it is the movie for you please
kindly keep your distance from me
[Music]
you